et que l'acier
nick edge qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète
nick que vous ayez perdu votre talent
d'acteur non
ce qui le dit en gros ils t'adorent mais
il a décidé de partir sur une autre
direction j'ai fini pour moi j'arrête le
cinéma tu peux appeler tous les contacts
on dira que c'était un immense honneur
d'avoir fait partie de la famille du
cinéma et d'avoir construit des légendes
on a un nouveau projet s'est payé un
million tu as invité à la fête
d'anniversaire d'un gentleman très
fortunés c'est absolument hors de
question perianes sortie est à juste à
jouer ton propre rouge on sait quoi sur
ce gars de toute façon est-ce qu'ils
bossent dans un truc louche ça va bien
se passer et va pas demander de le sucer
ou de béziers sa femme ou de le mater
pendant qu'ils baissent sa femme
j'espère bien que non
bienvenue à majorque mais ce ketch c'est
quoi le nom du mec à cette maison ah oui
pardon sur la vie va vouloir me voir
c'est moi à vie
ni cage
cet endroit est incroyable c'est pas ton
film préféré c'est le genre de question
à laquelle il est impossible de répondre
on peux pas en choisir qu'un
c'est un peu trop vite arrivé c'est
sensé et thomas c'est grotesque jetant
donne vingt mille dollars
[Musique]
la flèche on en abuse tué
en position je crois que c'est l'acteur
nikkei
je vous adore
les crous tout non j'ai 44 ans rien à
[__] de techcrunch 2 j'ai vu
volte-face et les ailes de l'enfer
qu'est ce que vous voulez on est de la
cia vous savez qui c'est votre ami un
des mecs les plus impitoyables qui
existe sur cette planète
vous devez des gouvernements des états
unis
[Musique]
trouver un moyen d'entrer dans cette
pièce
imagine bien refaire ce genre de choses
tu crois que je suis né pour ce rôle
parce qu'on a une autre mission
pour mamie travaillent pour le
gouvernement des états unis arrêtent de
me mentir
ce serait pas mais pistolet renoncé mais
pistolet non j'ai pas envie de te tuer
et non plus j'ai pas envie de toi et je
te
[Musique]
je suis ce [__] de nicolas
oh
ok
[Musique]